je poursuis la discussion avec michel
coulomb chroniqueur de cinéma bon sens
michel bonjour alors vous avez été un
des cofondateurs de ces prix jutra
aujourd'hui après tout ce qui s'est
passé est ce que québec cinéma avait le
choix ou est-ce qu'il fallait absolument
changer le nom de cette cérémonie
l'air était devenu irrespirable les
preuves sont là déjà il y avait ce livre
qui étaient sur la place publique et qui
forçait le débat mais le témoignage
quand le pu lire dans la presse
aujourd'hui est terrifiant c'est une
chose effrayante
ça a tout changé et ça tout fait
basculer par ailleurs l'intervention de
la ministre david qui rapidement a dit
il faut vraiment renverser la vapeur et
je ne veux pas que des prismes jutra
accéléré à mon avis le processus on de
vue ainsi ce sera aujourd'hui la journée
où le nom de claude jutra est disparu de
l'espace public mais à plein d'endroits
une salle à la cinémathèque les prix
jutra un prix à toronto
des noms de rue tout ça en une journée
on peut pas dire qu'on est traîné en
même temps c'est comme si on assistait
l'agonie de mourant depuis quelques
jours eh bien on a mis fin à ses
souffrances
c'est comme ça comment expliquer que
plusieurs aient dit c'était connu on le
savait et qui que rien n'ait été fait ce
que le fait que ce soit un artiste a
fait qu'on la dise enfin de façon
protégée depuis quelques jours mais je
réfléchis ou aux excès de l'admiration
il ya cent ans est un artiste il est un
peu à part cela dit les gens qui tenait
ce discours s'en tenait généralement à
des adolescents disait il avait 14 ans
ils étaient plus âgés plus âgés 40 50
ans avec un enfant de 14 ans ça me
paraît déjà un problème mais ça pour
plusieurs c'était acceptable
il était doux il était gentil sûrement
qui leur faisait pas de mal
allez dire ça à un avocat
ils veulent condamner quand même quand
on a vu cette histoire là le cas d'un
enfant de six ans que qui veut le vert
dont il avait par citéa depuis le début
de la semaine ils disaient voilà il ya
quelqu'un de plus jeune lui parlait de
cinq ans j'ai tenté de joindre cette
personne qui ne voulaient pas témoigner
bon mais là ça devenait effectivement
socialement inacceptable tant mieux pour
claude jutra c'est à dire que là ce
débat qui fait rage autour de mort sur
les 30 ans qu'ils aient disparu devenait
quelque chose d' intenable
on a mis un terme à ça il faudra laisser
autant son travail pour que les films
reviennent ils reprennent leur vie
pour le moment ce sera très difficile
est ce que c'est possible qu'on qu'on
garde quand on regarde l'oeuvre de
claude jutra de la même façon
aujourd'hui on y chercheront des signes
yves le vert dans son livre les énumère
des plans où ils regardent des garçons
mais ce sont pas des films malsain ni
des films pervers mon oncle antoine est
un grand film
le sim qui la felix leclerc
sélectionneur troubadours est un film de
référence
si on veut voir félix leclerc ou est un
film sur la jeunesse québécoise la fin
des années 60 tout ça demeure à tout
prendre il ya des films fondateurs du
cinéma d'auteur québécois ça va demeurer
dans les universités on veut l'enseigné
et puis on ajoutera et vous savez qu'en
2016 ou mois de février il s'est passé
une chose terrible
un livre est paru un témoignage a tout
changé
ça fera partie de l'histoire de claude
jutra partir de maintenant on n'y peut
plus rien mes oeuvres vont rester parce
qu elle pas un danger alors vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure de diriger en
icône
un homme comme claude jutra il faut en
tirer des leçons mais tirer des leçons
aussi de l'acceptabilité présumé de cas
comme un homme de 50 ans avec quelqu'un
de 14 ans au fin de sa vie artistique
qui pourrait permettre tout sens si ça
devrait être non on devrait dans une
société de zéro tolérance
or on a constaté que l'amitié et
l'admiration bon aussi la proximité des
gens du milieu permettait d'accepter ces
choses-là trop longtemps il ya des gens
sur moi quand on écrit les jutra il ya
donc plusieurs années qu'ils savaient et
qui n'ont pas levé la main et
sérieusement ce sont ces personnes là
qui ont fait beaucoup de tort à sa
réputation
on aurait pu éviter ce qui m'apparaît
une forme de carnage cette destruction
d'un homme sur la place publique
si on n'avait pas avancé si on n'était
pas avancer c'était pas avancé sur ce
terrain leur jeu c'est extrêmement
regrettable comme tout le monde est en
deuil
parce que la vraie deuil douloureux il
ya une vraie admiration c'était un grand
cinéphile c'est quelqu'un qui était le
début qui est des raisons qui
travaillait avec les gens du cinéma
direct c'est un excellent moteur
son nom est associé à plusieurs oeuvres
qu'on aime beaucoup il a été là du début
des années 50
très présent avec norman mclaren
notamment puisqu'il a fait l'été une
chaîne avec lui de fait une formidable
jusqu'aux années 80 c'est une période
importante de notre cinéma et il était
au four et au moulin il a fait ici à
radio-canada des émissions télévision il
était l'animateur d'émissions sur le
cinéma image en boîte et compagnie vous
voyez c'est quelqu'un auquel on s'est
référée pendant des années on l'a citée
à de nombreuses reprises on lui a rendu
hommage à de nombreuses occasions
c'est donc une déconfiture mais aussi un
deuil que les cinéphiles
devront faire tranquillement c'était un
peu brute heures et c'est la poussière
retombée après on retrouvera notre
rapport avec à ses oeuvres comme c'est
le cas pour plusieurs artistes on a
appris plein de choses sont différents
artistes certains lisent pas louis
ferdinand céline parce qu'il était
antisémite et donc lui trouve une grande
admiration woody allen a été blanchi des
accusations qui pesaient sur lui
mais roman polanski effectivement c'est
trouver dans cette situation là il
pourrait toujours être extradé aux états
unis
on apprend à vivre avec ça pour le
moment c'est un deuil
c'est une journée difficile mais ce sont
des gestes nécessaires quand il poser
aujourd'hui est responsable de la part
du milieu du cinéma comme celle que l'on
voit